two lyrics and you're the chairman of
the economic science prize committee
please tell us about this year's prize
to Jean it all from France yeah so this
price is about market power and
regulation so we typically think about
the profit profit motive as being quite
benign you know small firms wanting to
become big but once you are big once
you're a big firm the profit motive
maybe it's not so benign anymore you may
want to dominate the market you may want
to exploit your customers to exclude
competitors and then the question is
what sort of regulations and competition
policy do want to put in place so that
the also the large and mighty firms will
act in society's best interests it's a
lot big firms big companies how does
this price affect us normal people oh it
effects us well I should say we are
affected by big firms all the time and
some of those big firms or monopoly
providers of you know electricity or
telecommunication or transport services
and the quality of those services and
the price that we pay matters to all of
us that's right when it did he do is
research that you have awarded this year
and it started in the early 1990s and it
hasn't ended yet he is still a very very
active researcher in this field
it is a big deal of research in economic
sciences yes industrial organization is
a fairly big field it's one of the
specializations that will be offered in
most universities what kind of methods
to do we use and its kind of research
this is big statistical analysis and
Shawn to roll is primarily a theorist
and the method that he uses is something
called game theory that allows you to
study strategic interaction between
players that you know that they have an
impact on each other if you want to know
more about this topic is it anything we
can read from him or is that the website
we can go to and what you want oh yeah
absolutely you should go to Nobel Prize
org and depending on your ambition you
read just the Friday just a press
release or we have a five page summary
and we also have if you really want to
go deeply into this field there is a
document called advanced scientific
information that is about 40 pages long
and describes in much greater detail
what are two roles scientific
achievement was it hard to make this
year's decision yes and no it's always a
it's been clear for some time that this
control is worthy recipient and the
question has been precisely for what and
alone or with whom and when and this
price is about taming the market in the
market economy we have marketing money
for very long time in history and it's
still a problem changing the market with
these days when we have
of regulations and so on why is it so
hard to tame the market well these big
actors will have agendas and sometimes
those agendas are perfectly aligned with
everyone's interest and sometimes they
are not and the challenge of regulatory
policy is to not intervene when we have
aligned interest and then we should let
creativity flow and the businesses grow
but when interests are not so well alone
we need to make sure that people who are
profit-seeking don't make more damage
than the value that they create and what
do you ask economic scientist think was
the most surprising of his research when
we are studying in his work oh I've been
startled over and over again by by his
production I find it this is this is a
little bit like asking people to to say
which of their children are the noises
that I find that very difficult sorry
okay and that's his theory work on a
national level or a global level because
it's very complicated things his
theoretical framework is is quite
general of course many of the malls that
he has proposed presume that there is a
single regulator but he has also been
involved in understanding what happens
if you have multiple regulators and what
are the coordination problems involved
so he is more than any other economists
I know he is very keen to address all
the big problems and never shy away
from any problem and as he was saying at
the the press conference he thinks that
policy coordination both in banking and
in many other industries it's on the
very top of our professional agenda and
the world is lovely recovering from a
big economic crisis of years ago can
this annalynne and results help up the
world economy do you think yes I think
that some more of chanterelles proposals
in particular in the field of banking
regulation might help to reduce the
probability that such prices will look
her again in the financial sector and
finally is this a political price I
think that this is not really a
political price you can never quite
disentangle the way we analyze questions
from our political preconceptions but I
think to a very high degree Jean tirol
achieves this and he like an engineer he
he offers a toolkit for problem solving
that is applicable no matter what your
political preference I think both the
Socialists and the Conservatives would
want to take advantage of his
professional analysis so you think we
can be optimist about the economic
future now since we have all these not
know yet note if we had more researchers
like Jean to roll I think it would be
very good thing for the world thank you
very much